[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute habe ich für euch
eine richtig leckere und hübsche torte
und zwar liebe ich ja kinder bueno aber
noch leckerer als das original finde ich
die light-variante die gibt es
mittlerweile dauerhaft überall zu kaufen
und lessing habe ich mir was richtig
leckeres einfallen lassen
ich habe in meiner 85 cm springform
gebacken und zwar habe ich einen
leckeren betritt boden gewachsen
den habe ich euch bereits abgefilmt und
ich schreibe euch nochmal alles in die
infobox die genaue mengenangaben und die
anleitung zum video für die bruno kleen
benötigen wir 600 milliliter sahne 500
gramm ohne 200 gramm weiße geschmolzene
kuvertüre die durfte schon 15 minuten
lang abkühlen
außerdem acht kinder bueno 150 gramm
gemahlene haselnüsse 11 telefonat und
eineinhalb esslöffel vanille extrakt
auch hier haben wir wieder eine schnelle
und einfache zubereitung das kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich gar nicht anders von mir
wir geben einfach die kalte sahne und
die mascarpone in die rührschüssel
schlagen dass eine halbe minute an und
anschließend gehen wir noch dass sara
packmittel zu
viele von euch fragen was die anstelle
des landeplatzes benutzen können
natürlich könnt ihr dann auch seines
stall verwenden ich habe aber das gefühl
dass man mit dem sommerbad immer auf der
sicheren seite ist denn das findet
einfach viel schneller viel stärker und
außerdem ist es hochgerechnet auch viel
günstiger als sahne steif
nach circa ein bis eineinhalb minuten
ist die sahne mascarpone creme auch
schon steib und jetzt kommt noch die
geschmolzene kuvertüre mit hinein
wie gesagt ist es ganz wichtig dass ihr
sie abkühlen lässt denn wenn es noch
lauwarm ist dann wird euch designerin
man sieht auch bei mir es war auch
wirklich sehr hey ich hab ihm einem auge
gehabt ein wenig ist es bei mir auch
gewonnen das macht zwar gar nicht nur
für die optik ein bisschen schade aber
dem geschmack todes trotzdem keinen
abbruch
anschließend geben wir noch die
gemahlenen haben und gerne und das
vanille extrakt mit hinzu nachdem das
weingut unter home wurde ist die creme
eigentlich schon fertig fand aber ganz
nett noch ein paar bruchstücke
hineinzugeben das war auch im anstellt
super und wenn man drauf gebissen hat
hat man sich eigentlich immer gefreut
wenn man so ein stück erwischt hat also
das könnt ihr optional auch noch dazu
geben auf meine tortenplatte gebe ich
jetzt den ersten von drei bilden und
mache den tortenring drumherum
jetzt wird das ganze geschichte und da
gebe ich als erstes die hälfte meiner
cam drauf und dann wird das ganze klappt
verstecken
darüber kommt dann der zweite boden und
wird ganz leicht angedrückt
ich glaube hier konntet ihr ganz gut
sehen wie weit die böden sind aber ihr
müsst ihr nicht noch mal trinken wenn
ihr möchtet tut das gerne mit ein
bisschen milch oder ein bisschen kaaba
aber ich finde das war nicht nötig jetzt
gebe ich noch die zweite hälfte der
klärt auf und streicht auch schön glatt
anschließend kommt der deckel drauf und
hier nämlich immer den boden des biscuit
denn der ist immer richtig schön glatt
jetzt gebe ich die torte für circa drei
bis vier stunden in den kühlschrank denn
dann kann auch die weiße kuvertüre
schönau herten und nach der schulzeit
bestreite ich das dann dünn mit sahne
insgesamt habe ich mir hier 400 gramm
sahne aufgeschlagen ihr benötigt ca 150
gramm für die seiten und für die
oberfläche und den rest die brauchen wir
dann nachher für die deko nachdem die
torte mit der badedüne eingestrichen
wurde geben wir noch an den rand der
torte sie bruno und war kleben die wie
von alleine durch die sahne
[Musik]
wenn der rand ganz schön geschmückt ist
mit dem bus geht's weiter mit der
restlichen sahne hier gebe ich noch
gefühlt sicher ein bis eineinhalb
teelöffel backpulver denn ich war da ein
bisschen pingelig die creme in dem bruno
ist ja auch in schneeweiß und deswegen
wollte die auch noch mal ein bisschen
einfärben
so sieht die sahne auch schon viel
besser aus und jetzt nehme ich hier
meine lieblings fülle ihr wisst schon
die 1 m von wilden und dekorieren meine
torte damit
[Musik]
eigentlich finde ich ja dass die schüler
die ganze arbeit erledigt werden sobald
ihr die wanne daraus sprit kommt einfach
in richtig hübsche großen muster heraus
ihr könnt natürlich eurer fantasie wie
immer freien lauf lassen
ich fand es so ganz schön sagt mir doch
gerne eure kreationen ich bin super
gespannt
ich zeige euch natürlich auch noch im
anschnitt und ich finde dass die themen
total ein kinder grünewald erinnert denn
ihr habt ihr die haare liste mit drin
vor allem mit dem banner extrakt super
fein und ihr habt vor allem ein richtig
angenehmes mundgefühl ich wünsche euch
jetzt ganz viel spaß beim zubereiten
dieser richtig hübschen torte und wenn
euch das video gefallen hat dann lassen
wir doch gerne ein abo da damit ihr auch
keines meiner videos mehr verpasst bis
zum nächsten mal auf s kitchen